bonjour bonjour à tous si je suis ici
devant vous si j'ai décidé de rejoindre
la grande famille des républicain c'est
parce que j'en suis convaincu nous
pouvons ensemble porter une écologie
modérée et
réaliste avec le Grenel de
l'environnement le Grenel de la mer
Nicolas Sarkozy a su montrer qu'avec de
la volonté et une vision pragmatique de
l'écologie on pouvait rassembler et
faire bouger les choses personnellement
j'en ai assez des discours culpabilisant
d'onneur de leçon qui sont à l'opposé de
l'écologie que je souhaite porter
aujourd'hui oui nous voulons tous un air
sain à respirer une planète en bonne
santé pour nos enfants mais pour cela il
va falloir se retrousser les manches
voir le monde tel qu'il est voir le
monde tel que nous devons le changer
aujourd'hui et agir je préfère les actes
aux professions de foi les faits au
principes je suis de ceux qui pensent
qu'il vaut mieux la moitié de quelque
chose que l'intégralité de rien du
tout aujourd'hui on peut donner du sens
au progrès on peut réconcilier écologie
et
économie oui on peut être pêcheur sans
être pilleur on peut être armateur sans
faire de Maré noire on peut être
industriel et révolutionner la
conception de produit il n'y a pas quand
vous quand on voudrait nous le faire
croire les Gentils qui parleraient aux
arbres d'un côté et de l'autre les
méchants qui habiteraient dans les ville
il y a partout ici des gens comme vous
et moi qui voulons que les choses
changent et qui voulons une planète
meilleure mais pour cela il va falloir
oser il va falloir innover il va falloir
accepter le débat il va falloir prendre
des risques et c'est pour ça que je suis
avec vous parce que c'est possible et
parce que ce défi à relever est
passionnant républain merci